oh yeah oh yeah
never really before in history have we
had the chance to compare
the same high budget films side by side
of itself
the snyder version feels like it has
more momentum and weight the human lift
is the hardest thing to do in cg you
will love me
man steppenwolf just looks like a dude
[Laughter]
huge thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring
today's episode stick around to the end
to find out how you can get
three months free hey what's up everyone
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react today we are
looking at some incredible marvel movies
scratch that no you heard that right
today we're looking at not just the
justice league but the snyder cut
and kind of comparing the two because a
lot of work was done
to make sure the snyder cut could happen
and i want to look at the differences
and a lot of money was spent too how
expensive was this movie because it's
like
they filmed the movie then they filmed
all the reshoots they did all the visual
effects for the original cut of the
movie and then for the reshoots
and then for the snyder cut each time
there's money being spent
it's probably more than you think it's
probably the answer to that but no one
will know
they'll keep that under lock and key not
even the
mass detective himself batman could
figure that out i'm willing to wager
everybody asked us to react to this is
that super cool
so hey we like those comments keep them
coming it helps us know what to look at
in terms of just like the idea of doing
something like this cinematically
is crazy it is like unprecedented in
terms of film history because movie
studios don't go back
to revisit their stuff they'll like make
a sequel or whatever it's
the first time as far as we can tell
right where it's like okay cool everyone
wanted this original version fine we'll
go and do it again
yeah like normally when you see a
director's cut it's just it's using the
same source material with just slightly
different editing like with blade runner
you know it's like it's basically the
same movie just with a few different
implications what they didn't do is they
didn't go back and reshoot blade runner
again to make a new version of the
original blade runner
never really before in history have we
had the chance to compare
yes exactly high budget films side by
side of itself
exactly which is why a close frame by
frame study of
the snyder cut versus the weaving cut is
a film school in the box because you can
infer everything from how does the
visual effects
approach differ from how does the script
writing and story level differ from
how long a shot's being held to what
sequences are rearranged and what else
they reshot
for the weeden cut versus the snyder cut
you learn quite a bit from it barry
allen
right away the color correction approach
is different look at the skin tone
difference period right like in terms of
the reds how much
more intensely colorful the wien justice
league is versus snyder
color grading starts delving into the
world of visual effects like arguably
color grading is
visual effects it's you taking your film
and manipulating the colors putting
vignettes on masking certain things out
you know swapping the blue hue of the
sky for more of a
gold or something like that like that's
visual effects people think of
color grading as just like dropping a
filter on top of footage and just it
does what it does and it's like no
there's actually a lot of specific
attention played out in different parts
of an image just to
get those colors and lighting contrast
right for for everybody who kind of like
makes fun of like oh zack center justice
league is like oh it's all muted and
stuff
that's like well no he's still getting
tonality out of it snyder's almost has
like a metallic look to it
yeah the other thing is also a big
difference in the snider cut
square frame for three versus widescreen
so this is actually something that i
think is really interesting it's a huge
huge thing i mean
it became a meme right oh the snyder's
vision here's the thing i think is
interesting about 4-3
i've always felt that super widescreen
for superhero movies makes the
superheroes look small like when there's
a big
vista and the person doesn't quite fit
in that frame
like just from a visual standpoint i've
always felt like it makes human
figures and wide vistas look tiny which
is not the
emotional feeling of superheroes
superhumans are about big larger than
life characters so weirdly enough when i
look at the square format stuff
comparing the two movies when i watched
it
i actually really liked the square form
because it made the
individual characters feel like these
like god like figures more so than i
think widescreen does
i'm pretty sure the original justice
league movie was finished
at the wide screen the vfx shots were
finished at that aspect ratio did they
have to go back and re-render them with
the extra resolution up on top and
bottom
this movie is why it's important to have
a good file naming convention structure
for your project
because you never know when you need to
go back and open up those
old files you can't have you can't open
up that folder and be like
oh shot 30-1 version three final final
four
oh which one is it no you can't have
that and that's all on weta like they
did such a good job being able to like
bring up their old project files but
here's the thing it's one thing to be
able to like open up the old project
files but you can't just like
make it rework for the new stuff that
they're adding here
we're gonna have to like dive into that
[Music]
here
so i think it is time to address
probably the
biggest elephant in the room
steppenwolf and i think it's very safe
to say
that one is quite a bit cooler than the
other
that's a mild way of putting it man
steppenwolf just looks like a dude in
the 2017 version no like he is
straight up just a dude i think old
steppenwolf's name would be like brody
the original steppenwolf which is okay
to clarify
the steppenwolf we see in justice league
is not the original steppenwolf the one
we see in the snyder cut
is the original that was the original
design they they had it this character
before joss whedon came on board like it
looked like that
and they redesigned him i don't not
intentionally to make him look lame but
that was the result
so one thing that is interesting to me
looking at the character design right
one of them i just don't buy
winning against a bunch of amazon super
heroes right like
the one then this giant scaly metal
thing is like i buy a bunch of people
holding it and building it up
it doesn't quite work as well if it's
this guy
in this costume with the sort of
medieval looking armor and you have
eight different amazons holding him down
she doesn't quite have the same impact
i will say when i when i was watching it
i found myself like just
exploring the physicality of this cg
creature
way more just looking at his like chest
and looking at the little like the way
his
shoulders are built like my eye had
something to do with like
during it you know seven wolf's armor is
super detailed right it's like hyper
detail there's little bits everywhere
now there's a big danger to doing
something like that because it can very
quickly become
noise and it would be a danger of you
losing any of his form if you did that
there's two things they did to to fix
that one
is his silhouette is super clean and
smooth the fact that the suit is so
shiny
you can still see the you know bright
white outlines of his of his body as he
moves
there's not little spikes everywhere
that's one of the problems we run into
with the transformers robots
actually yeah there's not really a
readable silhouette but
there's another thing that they do so
imagine somebody wearing a hyper
detailed polka dot outfit you know maybe
maybe the silhouette is smooth but it's
still just noise everywhere right
well that's what you could have had
happen with steppenwolf and that is what
happens with this helmet in the 2017
version
is that it's just a bunch of squiggles
which is basically the same thing as
just noise
in the new version there's a pattern
almost like the direction of your hair
to all the pieces of his armor and one
of the things the human eye is
surprisingly good at
is detecting parallel lines and then
changes in those lines
like i could put a big like pile of
noodles on the floor i could take and
they could have them all point the same
direction and i could
take down that before by the way i could
take one noodle
and turn it from the direction of all
the others and you can just look at it
and immediately
that noodles in the wrong spot yeah and
like it seems
normal until you think about like your
eye can process a thousand objects and
immediately tell
instantly when one is not aligned and
that's the thing that they're relying
upon with steppenwolf's armor is that by
doing the pattern and the flow to it
you're also getting shape like clear
distinct like macro shapes in his armory
even though it's made out of a bunch of
micro shapes
and then some of the animations with the
new model you can see in in some of the
sequences it's just it's a wavier
animation set they went in and read and
just tweaked it and like you can look at
some of the movements in earlier
versions
and then see where it ends up in the
snyder cut you can actually see it
evolve from being like
this feels floaty to like oh this feels
like a little more like there's
something there and there's momentum
behind it
there's one shot of steppenwolf that
literally made my jaw just drop when i
saw it
like just take a take care to look at
the interaction between the liquid and
cg characters
oh oh yeah that's a 3d polo right there
oh
yeah just put a puddle in there make it
harder
hey do you want this you want this shot
to be a little harder for everybody
put puddle in there get the pot get some
water oh but it's more than just the
puddle there's mud that's coming up
the water's interacting with it that's
so dope that's sick
i saw that i was like oh my god people
have no idea how much effort just went
into that one small moment to really
like merge and marry steppenwolf with
the scene
it's small tricks like that that really
helps sell cg objects as being real
interaction but i can see that mud in
the water being actual displacement from
a real person
just watch it stick under his left foot
the way that stick moves a little splash
in the water there i don't think that's
cg but look at the size of his foot
no one's walking around with size 48
feet bigger
big old boots dog it's just the
awareness to make a stick bounce in the
perfectly realistic way like that
that's just good artistic detail ah i
think that the stick feels real to me
yeah it feels real to me too
maybe wedda will let us know yeah no
here i actually would be
super interested to see a breakdown of
this specific shot
whata hbo whoever warner brothers make
it happen
[Music]
perhaps a snider for showing the stunt
people hit the ground when they do this
stuff
like in the original cut she hits the
wall and it cuts away it's like the wall
impact isn't what's
important it's the impact on the ground
that's important i mean anybody can go
it's the it's the wreck yeah
snyder is someone who i think when you
look at his work is someone who is like
obsessed with the dynamics of the human
body and and stunt people in their
movement
i think it shows because it's the snyder
version feels like it has more momentum
and weight
so she's going to make a run for it
there's a real cost here
needs to get out with the box right
they're going to have to break the
wooden supports in order to drop
gates trapping themselves trapping
themselves into the hole
knowingly doing so to me this is a huge
difference between the two
these shots here of these amazons
knocking down the pillars done in slow
motion look at how many more there are
zack snyder is so in love with the human
form that he gives you the entire
wind up all the way around which gives
you the sense of weight and the
heaviness of it what do you get in the
weeden cut you get the last bit of it of
just the impact
it's not about the impact it's about
this herculean effort to like
throw this hammer all the way around
just like these are giant
larger than life beings destroying
things it's so much more intense to
build up
look at how much you're gonna miss in
the original cut of just their struggle
holding it up and how much of a buildup
it is
[Music]
long long slide shots all the way and
slow all the way and you see this
finality of it closing as opposed to in
the
again and justice league is just like
cool okay they're just trapped in
because there's no point
and then what's crazy here is that in
the original justice league
they just leave and then he busts
through the wall and chases after them
but in the snyder cut you you're like
there are hundreds of people in that
thing and it's now
falling into the ocean they are all
dying right now you're just like
when i watched the snider cut of this i
was just like like
my jaw was literally dropped so this was
so much cooler in the snider cut
and we're not even talking about the
visual effects there's so much like
right there
look at the shot look at this shot this
amazing
shot he's arguably a flawless shot like
the physics are perfect the smoke is
perfect the lighting's great
like this was definitely a money shot on
their list of like important
shots big money shot the dust getting in
there water interaction
that's my favorite detail that's pretty
cool
and the glass melts that's amazing
[Music]
some artists have to make a perfect
movie quality cg hot dog
i think i say overall this scene is
pretty dang great
like my my misgivings for like how it
actually happened with
her and momentum and all that stuff like
it doesn't matter he saves the woman
from a car crash
in a really cool slo-mo way how do you
think they filmed that though
i imagine she's on a wire it's kind of
like a wire
but i think it's actually a motion
control arm
she's got her hair pulled back so all of
the hair you see is computer generated
they did the cg hair also for wonder
woman when she's moving really fast in
that fight scene
and she's ramping all over the place her
hair wouldn't move like that if you just
did regular speed ramps they had to take
her hair out
but there's another aspect of her that's
computer generated that you might not
have realized
her clothes oh really because they need
a ripple in their correct way
yeah that that's textbook oh you think
you know what cg
what's cg in this shot you're like oh
yeah what about all her hair and her
coat oh
no you didn't look real
[Laughter]
notice how he's being very careful to
keep his hands outstretched and not
actually
pressing down on her because they knew
that they're going to have to replace
all of that
so they didn't want to have like him
physically
conforming his hand to clothing that's
not there yet
they actually nailed the the surface
contact shadows between his hand and her
clothes
really well
there are moments in the movie in the
snyder cut that they needed to do
basically reshoots without reshooting so
what do they do
well they probably used old footage they
used old footage so there's a scene
between dark side and superman
and he's like all like sad and whatnot
but it's from man of steel
after zod dies that's like the actual
moment from the movie
years ago they added a little bit of a
cg tear going down his face too
the only thing jank is the shadow from
darkseid as we talked about in the harry
potter piece it's really hard to add
shadow on something that's already lit
but i mean that being said they did a
really good job here it doesn't take you
out of it at all
it's just a cool detail that it's like
you know in order to make something
happen you pull out all the stops to you
know just do what's necessary oh you got
to use old footage
well make it work
[Music]
can we ask you some questions a full
podcast
well in that case another thing that
blew me away when i went back to
re-watch the justice league was that the
snyder cut opens on this
really like moody moment of superman
dying and yelling and sound waves going
out and then the original justice league
opens up with
hi i'm superman for those of you who
don't know the story
henry cavill was currently working on
mission impossible five
six something like that mission bothell
mustache edition he was contractually
obligated to keep that mustache he
couldn't shave it for these reshoots and
they're like ah
fix it in post right well the human lip
is the hardest thing to do in cg so in
the new version
this is just not present at all it was
completely cut
there is no reshoot of henry cavill with
a mustache in the snyder cut
because those were reshoots for the
weaving cut originally right yeah
but you know what zack snyder he's doing
away with joss whedon's original vision
you know
and i think we should bring it back we
should bring back the weed and cut
so i think we need to give superman the
mustache he deserves
[Laughter]
we have all of this incredible reference
footage from
mission impossible of henry cavill with
the mustache what if we deep fake the
mustache
back onto all of the superman shots
because superman needs a mustache
that's right we are releasing the
mustache cut so subscribe for that video
it's coming out very soon
don't forget we got you know peter here
and he doesn't do things
not at 900 percent i mean how big would
superman's mustache actually be good
question i mean you guys know how
superman shaves right
they address this there's a canon
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey guys jake here back with today's
sponsor expressvpn now you might think
brand integrations are an unimportant
part of this show
but i can assure you you've never seen
somebody react
to brand information the way that i'm
about to so let's get started with a
little segment that i like to call
jake reacts to the best things that i
learned about expressvpn
today what if i told you that expressvpn
invests only in premium
servers which makes their service
consistently faster than
almost any other vpn provider out there
go did you hear that
did you hear that oh my gosh that's
crazy something you might also not know
about expressvpn is that they have 24
7 customer support when you get in
contact with them
your questions are going to be answered
in seconds
what what what
no way 24 7 customer support
how is that even possible they must have
people on the phone
all day working in three shifts in a
giant warehouse
okay i got the night shift i gotta go
answer questions
from people calling in messaging in
expressvpn asking how do i connect to
servers in other countries
how do i get information how do i get
content that's on netflix china
i don't know if they even have netflix
over there wow
another thing you might not know about
expressvpn is that they were rated the
number one
vpn service by cnet tech radar
and the verge
no way no way
how about that reaction
now we use expressvpn over here because
it's simple it's reliable it's fast they
have great customer support
and you never have to think about it you
just turn it on and all of a sudden
your information is secure it's
encrypted and you have access
to any server that they have in over 94
countries
which gives you access to all the
content on the platforms in those
countries
so anyways if you guys are interested
head on over to expressvpn.com
corridor crew to find out how you can
get three months free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
corridor crew what
you got to be kidding me no way
[Music]
what a weird thing to exist it takes so
it's right there's so many things that
had to come together for
this movie to exist it's one of these
weird artifacts of film history
that happens so rarely that when it does
it warrants your attention
and you know what if you're in the film
definitely recommend
going frame by frame and really thinking
about what the differences are and how
they affect the final product and your
perception of the final product
you know there's a lot of comments on in
these threads talking about how great
dungeons and daddies is
no people liking the podcast yeah so
people are listening i've been doing
this podcast called dungeons and daddies
it's a d d podcast
this last year also been helping out my
dad with uh his book which
describes his uh escape from the chinese
cultural revolution by swimming the
channel
between china and hong kong which is
like a five or six mile swim which is
very long yeah that like five or six
miles might not seem that long but if
you're swimming that how long did it
take
it took him eight hours eight hours of
swimming how did he not drown
uh flotation device the whole thing he
wrote a book about it i helped him out
with it what a story
it's called swimming to freedom you can
pre-order it right now it's on amazon
barnes and noble
yeah so yeah it's it's uh it's a good
it's why i'm here it's a good story
if you like these videos consider
subscribing we got them coming out every
single weekend two videos a week at
least
these days more yeah it's been crazy you
content gluttons
the mustache cut don't forget subscribe
if you don't miss it it's gonna be a
good time